here they are striated Caracara is doing
what they do best ravaging this is
exactly the type of scene a National
Geographic crew expect her to catch on
camera when they went to the frigid
Falkland Islands what they didn't expect
well the birds are better known by
another name
Johnny rooks which is one of those
old-time phrases for thieves pillagers
and mischief-makers these birds are also
good at destroying things like well
campsites for instance
besides simple vandals stealing food is
a specialty and once the rumor gets out
then a free meal is available the Johnny
rooks have themselves beat this thievery
isn't for personal enrichment
this is havoc for the heck of it and for
that purpose it doesn't get any better
than messing with toilet paper so why
does the crew here in the first place to
capture Johnny whoops as they reveal
their very own generation gap actually
more like a chasm and an old Johnny rook
wayde's into a bunch of adolescence to
take control of our Rockhopper penguin
carcass and teach these young punks a
thing or two about who's in charge dear
this adult looks like he's gonna kick
some tail feathers he does a thorough
and
after this thrashing the adult discovers
the young Johnny Rose still don't appear
to realize who rules this roost his mate
joins the fray
together they show they mean business
this is a mean nasty take-no-prisoners
Valley the adults win and celebrate with
a raucous victory
enjoy the spoils of victory the young
Johnny rooks get a one-way ticket to
Palookaville
this is a harsh desolate island and
finding food here is no easy task they
scour the coastline for anything edible
one thing is certain a penguin dinner
with the folks is not in their future